hey guys it is Monday yep whoops I
should have probably introduced myself
or said something else I'm John Dan I'm
Jeff and this is gamespot news good week
first up Mega Man is getting a new main
line entry Mega Man 11 the company also
revealed that a bunch of the classic
Mega Man games are coming to consoles
next year during a livestream
celebrating 30 years of the Blue Bomber
Capcom revealed that Mega Man 11 will
come out sometime in 2018
there's not many details at the moment
other than the news that the game will
come to ps4 Xbox one switch and PC and
we got a look at the sweet new graphics
during the reveal the developers said
that the overriding goal is to resurrect
Megaman and that they'll reveal more
details and next summer the whole place
over until then Capcom is releasing all
eight megaman x games on all major
platforms in summer 2018 Mega Man Legacy
Collection and Mega Man Legacy
Collection 2 will also make their way to
Nintendo's switch with some sort of
amiibo support the Mega Man collections
contain all the classic Mega Man games
with the first collection containing
Mega Man 1 to 6 and the second
containing Mega Man 7 to 10 the first
Legacy Collection will also feature a
rewind function that will also be added
to the existing ps4 Xbox one and PC
versions just it's 2017
how much would you pay for Assassin's
Creed 4 and another game that's the
titles I'd forgotten I mean 4 is a
really great game fantastic game
probably you know a small handful of
change well guess what full put your
change away it's free at the moment well
no at the moment don't sin that Ubisoft
is in the mood to celebrate and that's
good news for you and me so long as you
play on PC it's been 10 years since the
release of RTS World in Conflict so
between right now and December 11th you
can pick up welding conflict and its
expansions Soviet assault for none of
your dollars if real time strategy isn't
quite your speed in celebration of the
10 year anniversary of the first
Assassin's Creed game you can pick up
the very very good Assassin's Creed 4
Black Flag
which is indisputably the most piratey
Assassin's Creed game for free from
December 12th through to December 18th
in order to grab the freebies you need
to download the games through you play
on your PC and then you can keep them
forever and ever and ever last week I
was lucky enough to get to see Dan freak
out when they played a small promo for
the last Jedi and he ran
mm-hm got right out of there because I
don't want to see none of that marketing
material but I'm not the only one
running around before the last Jedi
comes out dice has made a bunch of new
changes to battlefront 2's progression
system that was a loose connection ahead
of the upcoming new content themed
around the last Jedi dice has addressed
more feedback regarding the rate at
which players are earning rewards a
common complaint is that credits are
accrued too slowly and that performance
barely factors in this has led some
players to run in circles in matches to
rack up rewards dice have made some
changes and all players will now receive
more rewards at the end of the match
with the top players receiving even more
the cap on credits ownable in arcade
mode has also been raised from 500
credits per day to 1500 credits the
final change sees the daily loot boxes
adjusted to give more crafting parts so
you can put them towards that specific
on advantage giving even though that's
totally what it says on its stock odd
since release dice have made many
adjustments to the game's progression
system dropping the cost of heroes and
removing microtransactions more
extensive customization could be on the
horizon but EA have said this may be
difficult due to the issues that could
raise with the Star Wars Canon so what
would need to be approved by Lucasfilm
to say nothing of Rey fighting Darth
Maul the last Jedi season of content
begins tomorrow on December 5th and
we'll add the new maps vehicles hero
units and a campaign chapter that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day and we'll be here
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday on
Felix is very quiet almost almost like a
am i you starting the first center you
can do it do as much of it we can wing
this one cuz it's all it's all a funny
story that actually happened this is a
funny story that actually happened
please enjoy the following and let me
just get in the zone
[Music]